hey great to be back on CNN we have
Texas Senator and author of unwoke Ted
Cruz okay and former psychology
Professor Jordan Peterson and opinion
columnist for the New York Times C
app okay
so here we go this first one is for you
do Republicans have a good answer to
address the Border crisis other than
busting migrants to Liberal cities o a
little dig there a
little it's actually very simple which
is secure the border and when you
apprehend someone send them home when
when Joe Biden started we had the lowest
rate of illegal immigration in 45 years
and he came in and he immediately
reimposed Catch and Release and It
produced the worst rate of illegal
immigration in our nation's history I I
spend a lot of time at the border I go
out on midnight Patrol with border
patrol agents really Pro many times you
you should come I I'll actually bring
you if you're interested in if you want
to see I I will tell you this actually
bill if you saw what was happening you
would be horrified because the people
being abused by the traffickers you
don't understand it till you see it
firsthand and it is it is immoral what's
happening at our Southern border I take
your word okay I don't have to go
um but but it is easy to fix because
what actually worked is we had an
agreement with Mexico that was called
the remain in Mexico agreement which
says that if someone crossed into Mexico
illegally from typically Central or
South America would remain in Mexico
while their Asylum case was proceeding
in the US and the numbers plummeted we
had the lowest rate as I said in 45
years and then Biden came in and ripped
that International agreement to shreds
and that's what produced now 8.4 million
illegal aliens since Biden's been
president boy I walked right into that
one I know I know you know this this is
part of your but all right let me ask it
a different way do you think if the we
attacked it from the reverse angle in
other words if we punish the employers
absolutely it would and you think we
should oh look I am all for E verify I
would absolutely punish the employers
and I've introduced legislation to do
that multiple times and what happened
your party must not like that because we
know cheap labor is good so look there
are a lot of Republicans who don't like
that they're fewer but but I do think
that the Republican party is changing I
think we're becoming much more of a blue
blue collar party which I think is a
very good thing okay uh this is
for they are switching aren't they yes
it's interesting the the parties are
kind of switching like who the elitists
are it used to be the country club
Republicans and now it's the the
chardonay sipping Democrat it's I know
you've written about it it's it's an
interesting Dosey Do the party do it's
almost happened completely in Canada now
the conservatives are basically the
workingclass party in Canada right yeah
look the the heart of the Republican
Party are truck drivers and steel
workers and cops and firefighters and I
think that is a fantastic shift I think
we should be the party of jobs we should
be the party of of people who want to
work harder okay
okay um for Jordan are men more
susceptible to loneliness than women
no no
well we know this so so at puberty women
become more sensitive to negative
emotion than men and then that's
permanent on average through the entire
life course and it looks like it's
associated with hormonal changes and so
cross-culturally women experience higher
levels of depression and anxiety and
shame and guilt all the negative
emotions that Clump together and so
loneliness is a pain related emotion and
women are more susceptible to that what
what do you now we everybody recognizes
that women girls mature faster than boys
I mean this is why they going out with
the upper class they and at any age they
usually don't want somebody exactly
their age even though this country is
like crazy for age appropriate God
forbid we go out of
that uh but what do you think if you had
to name a number pick of like how far
ahead the women are years wise well we
know women prefer men four years old or
cross-culturally four yeah yeah but and
it's not necessarily only a matter of
maturation it's also the case that women
are more attracted by by by
socioeconomic status and productivity
than are in relationship how many years
Head Start does a man need to match his
maturity level to a woman's level I
think
40 well there's wide wide individual
differences in that two uh learning a
lot about women here am I wrong about
that
is well I I'm okay yeah I would say I
have a different view of women from
Jordan what what do you mean different
well I I mean
the depression
anxiety um what else do we have that's
Nega everything negative no not
everything negative just because men are
much more likely to be aggressive and to
end up in prison and to be alcoholic and
they're over represented in learning
disabilities like there there are sex
differences in Psychopathology and
they're not all tilted negatively
towards women definitely not so but
negative emotion it's absolutely clear
that that's the case and it's the
biggest differences are in the countries
that have the most gendere equal
economies and socioeconomic structures
so the differences between men and women
in terms of sensitivity to negative
emotion maximize in
Scandinavia wow so Scandinavians are
also much happier than we are though
yeah comparatively their women are less
happy so I
mean I know I've seen those surveys too
I I find it a very difficult thing to
quantify happiness or it's it's kind of
like that pain Char in the hospital 1 to
10 like somebody's three is somebody
else's eight you know what I mean how
happy are they really in Scandinavia I I
don't know well it's I know this the
greatest country in the world right Ted
amen
hallelujah all right how will get that
one
wrong how will Joe mansion's decision ah
this happened today Joe Mansion West
Virginia senator decision not to seek
reelection impact the balance of power
in the Senate I saw a lot of gleeful
Democrats we got rid of Joe Mansion good
luck trying to elect another Democrat in
West Virginia John fedman will win
Dancing with the Stars before yeah I
mean he su succeeded Robert bird and but
I guess he's making noise about a third
party
run I think that he is one of the
several Democrats now who have decided
that something has to be done you know
to offer an alternative to Biden I mean
unfortunately Jill Stein has also jumped
into the race and that worked out really
well last time um so but I think that
the the balance of power in the Senate
is the bigger threat what do you think
about Joe Mansion you must have worked
with look I like Joe personally he's a
very affable guy but he he's so much
more conservative than most democ
Democrats so not running means
Republicans will win that seat and and
and in fact I would be willing to bet
the Democrats could you vote for a guy
like Joe Mansion no really he's not
conservative because I serve with him
and actually he votes on 90% of the
times for things that are terrible so
for example I watched the panel
discussion you had you were talking
about Iran and Hamas and and and I said
at the end of our interview that I
thought Biden had Direct responsibility
for this attack and and and you said why
let me give you one reason why Joe Biden
is responsible for a hundred billion
dollar going to the Ayatollah he made a
decision to do that and Iran funds Hamas
the Street Journal reported in September
they brought Hamas terrorists to Iran
and trained them in Iran to carry out
the attack and I start from a really
simple principle don't give money to
terrorists who want to kill us and and
that
unfortunately the Democrat part's on the
other side of that it's you went to
Harvard as you point out also you know
you know it you know cor man you're not
exactly a man of the people right I I I
try not to mention it though uh but you
know it's more complicated than that no
I actually don't think it is okay when
when the Ayatollah chance death to
America and death to Israel I believe
him but what's the complicated part is
what I was saying the people of Iran is
different than the regime but he didn't
give the money to the people he gave the
money to the Ayatollah the person he's
giving it to is the one who has pledged
he wants to murder as many Jews and as
many Americans as possible and giving
him Obama gave him $100 billion Biden
gave him a100 billion and that was
catastrophically foolish all right I'm
against that all right you you created
an we' got agreement no I mean I'm
against killing Americans
um for and I don't care who knows it all
right in less than one minute because r
on CNN Jordan you created an app that
teaches people how to write is that an
effective way to teach them to be
critical thinkers yes the most the most
profound way of learning to think is to
learn to write and edit in particular CU
that's how you get rid of the stupid
ideas I agree there there's three area
there's
thinking and then there's talking and
then there's writing and each one makes
you better writing you really do edit
yeah um talking is a is better than just
but what's just going on in your mind
that's where people get other people
edit when you're talking edit you yes
yeah and you don't obviously lots of
people say lots of stupid things but at
least you have some mechanism but what
goes on in your mind I mean this is the
problem with people say you know God
talked to me he didn't you talked to him
he didn't answer those are called
thoughts
M anyway thank you CNN great to be back
thank you T we'll see you next
week